the good anxiety man when you step into
a Toys R Us and you just have sensory
overload as a kid that's true yeah and
then you put them put the toys in your
shirt and then you walk out right
yeah
it's not what you guys do
[Music]
there's a Toronto Zoo I think it's
called the Toronto Zoo is now advising
its visitors to avoid showing videos and
photos on their cell phones to its
gorillas as they distracted oh yeah so
people are going up to the girls to be
like look look and then the gorilla's
life oh [__] that's crazy good trip out
probably that is me no but they're like
super getting interested and like really
wanting to just kind of like keep
watching and being stimulated by so he
wants a cell phone now yeah yeah this
thing [__] works on an ape brain too
yeah ultimate dopamine hit I show my
dogs and they go
but gorillas be able to be like this
though yeah yeah yeah I mean why don't
you give them an iPad see what he does I
want to see a gorilla with an iPad
that'll be pretty funny quote unquote we
just want the gorillas to be able to be
gorillas
yeah then let them go we want them to be
as natural as possible then you just
have them in the [__] zoo with no
challenges and they're making they're
making social media accounts for the
gorillas anyway
sure there is kind of an irony to this I
would go full force if I owned a zoo I
would put the gorillas inside like a
human-like environment or VR yeah and
I'll put them in overalls I'll be sick
too if you put uh VR inside of the
gorilla yeah dude and then he can just
play yeah one day it will be like today
is Doctor day and then the gorilla is
like wearing a doctor's outfit and he's
doing he's in a hospital let's see what
the doctor yeah Dr gorilla would do or
one day he's like a barista so he's like
a gorilla Barista it's like a Starbucks
I kind of do you want to see after a
gorilla on a phone for a whole day what
his feet looks like
like what's his algorithm because it
might be what's this for you page I bet
you it's it's just gorilla booty dude
it's gorilla butt it's at Banana bananas
gorilla's doing the cinnamon challenge
it's just gorillas in the wild gorillas
oh [__] oh damn that's so sad see
imagine what if they do that and then
same thing that happens to us happens to
them depression anxiety oh true we get
fat yeah the gorillas with blue hair
[Laughter]
sad gorilla
him I know that'd be crazy
and then they start forming two groups
one's like hardcore Christian gorillas
once wearing bulletproof vest yeah
nobody wants to do that let's give it to
the gorillas teach them how to do it and
do it Peter's gonna have a field day
with this one yeah except it might kill
you too yeah yeah
I think they can kill you but if we put
them in a problem dude a chimp can kill
us gorillas are even stronger that's a
chip but gorillas are different you
would trust a gorilla walking around the
zoo emptying the trash I would
that fool could throw the trash can at
you and then you die but it would be
cool like
that's it they have a radio you don't
think he's gonna while out at any moment
did you not Watch Planet of the Apes I
did I think a gorilla would be a better
security guard than a janitor a bouncer
yeah yeah a bouncer yeah
well how do they know what to read
when's your birthday
they could read they know sign language
and [__] you see Jane Goodall to train
them yeah but how do we tell them it's
it's the year 2024 it's 99. they can't
mask yeah that's what I'm saying they
gotta read the expiration date they
gotta learn all 50 states to see if it's
a real ID or not you just have to scan
it and if it goes ding then it's fine oh
nice that's true they put them in TSA
then I mean they would probably do a
better job they'd be nicer I think but
then now you don't even need them to
read the ID now you just put your ID and
it goes Ding and then there's a camera
so then all the gorillas got to do is
listen to the dude he was like now you
can go yeah and maybe let's keep one
thing about professions and industries
I got another one so um
humans be suing right yeah yeah humans
be suing Good Start mainly Americans we
need more construction workers because
there's a huge shortage you know so we
need and gorillas are good at climbing
like when you make skyscrapers I feel
like humans look fragile like they're
gonna fall and [__] but gorillas no
problem dude strong too yeah but they'll
be making rock climbing walls instead of
stairs for humans they don't have to be
the architecture dude they just gotta be
the the hammer guys yeah they still make
rock climbing stuff yeah make stairs
okay rock climbing the guy to bring the
steel beam up yeah we could do the
gorillas for that because the cranes
aren't useful yeah no because the crane
guy's gonna Sue yeah oh you're right
it's kind of like that old ass TV show
we used to watch with the humans
controlling dinosaurs remember that [__]
Park trolling dinosaurs no like the they
they would have like dinosaur armies
like you put like [__] missiles and
Rockets on your dinosaur oh I kind of
remember remember that [__] because they
had toys and stuff like that yeah is
this a cartoon yeah and then humans
would control like I used to have these
toys this is like the He-man era is that
Cadillacs and dinosaurs I forgot but it
was so you could have a dinosaur and
then they would have all these missiles
and weapons on it and you ride them you
put like a saddle on it yeah wait that
sounds familiar now yeah you need to
bring that back I feel like Taiko will
love that dinosaur is a missile hey it's
pretty dope man kid toys like little
boys toys do they have the same cool
[__] that what does that sound weird it
sounds like a lot of it is pussified
like they don't have like [__]
warrior [__] no more and like straight
up realistic looking guns are all out of
time they have social justice league
a lot of it is pride though that's whack
so it's like Ninja Turtles but they have
a protest sign and [__] there's no more
nunchucks nunchucks I think are okay
they slip right in the uh just mainly
guns and stuff that's whack GI Joe don't
come with like guns and stuff Joe's guns
shot lasers and they never hit anybody
yeah and if it hit somebody that guy
magically ended up a robot
that's true yeah I remember buying
airsofts all day and just playing
outside with it now we can't even do it
well even in the even in Ninja Turtles
Leonardo always had swords but he always
stuck into the roof and kicked you yeah
yeah
it was a sick move though in the comics
yeah but not in the not in the actual
kid stuff dude
he's not around kids I see kids they'll
turn a [__] rock into a toy in Hawaii
Joe's always around kids those kids are
on their [__] iPads all the time a
lot of kids are in Hawaii is different
though you see kids come out the bus
with boogie boards yeah yo let's go hit
that [__] wave I think Hawaii's still
30 years old
Hawaii still feels normal though you see
kids roughhousing playing playing
outside that's true in La I feel like
I don't even see any [__] kids
playing outside no more nowhere in the
exact same neighborhood that I played
outside in yeah isn't that crazy except
the Jewish communities when you're
around Fairfax and Melrose they're still
normal they're still they're just on a
dirty ass couch jumping
outside what are we saying about
Orthodox Jews and Melrose I love them
is that what he said
I love them oh man kid's not kids no
more man oh you know how you can tell if
kids don't play with toys then they
wouldn't be stalking them as much in
Walmart and Target and the biggest
content for kids online is toy reviews
right yeah that's true that and like
baby sharks dude forever right forever I
don't think I've seen a kid bored with
like like stop just completely not doing
toys like I've always seen kids like
[__] hold and stuff I do think the
toy era for Our Generation though is way
different from than we have the best
toys and [__] we have so much variety
because when I was in um I was the other
day I was just swimming and these kids
had water guns like [__] Desert
Eagles and [__] and they're just filling
it up [__] yeah like and I was like
oh they still sell those plastic squirt
guns
I thought that they would be too woke
for that [__] those are those are
evergreen toys
California oh but kids like playing with
guns they like turning in love Yeah a
stick is a gun yeah but you know what
the the I'm sure the market is lower
only because of uh fortnite online yeah
because now it's like you don't have
Toys R Us you don't have KB oh you don't
have all these like stories because
everyone just buys toys online KB Toys
but that's like different because when
you're looking at like a picture on
Amazon it's different than when you were
at the [__] store and you would just
see every action figure lined up and
you're trying to go through them to see
where your favorite characters are yeah
and then like all the Spider-Man
Wolverines are gone so you just settle
for Omega Red
Omega Red all they have now is Target
that anxiety of the good anxiety man
when you step into a Toys R Us and you
just have sensory overload as a kid
that's true he's just pissing your pants
and you're running everywhere and then
you skip those two aisles that's all
pink and for girls and then you just put
them put the toys in your shirt and then
you walk out right
yeah
it's not what you guys do that's true
does taika know that feeling of going
into a toy store not like a 100 toy
store like Toys R Us but if we go to a
Target he always wants to stop by the
toy section oh yeah that's only like a
couple aisles
like the whole it's an amusement park
but nowadays though like as far as like
toy selection accessibility target has
is the number one dude no one like
Worldstar gets pretty Walmart oh yeah
Walmart yeah yeah I just remember always
trying to get like the Super Soaker with
the backpack and everything like that
like the six canisters and I would run
over to my parents they'd be like no
yeah I'm not gonna pay two hundred
dollars do you remember where they had a
suit but Tommy has one I know Tommy's a
loser had a Super Soaker that had like
an eye piece and it was voice activated
no I remember that
commercial the kids going fire fire and
it's like
an ear and it just shoots out and it
worked like [__] yeah yeah I heard it
worked like really badly dude water
water fights were the best though like
having war with water guns like we had a
Gatling gun one that was like on a
[__] tripod
and then when you hit the button it
would go
like battery operated yeah that was so
and no matter what somebody's still
getting hit in the face with a water
balloon and makes them cry yeah as
always yeah dude when you're a little
kid Super Soakers actually hurt because
you it's like a lot of pressure yeah you
gotta go like this yeah like this
and then you go
I don't know it's so sensual man bring
back war and guns dude break back whoa
but they still have Super Soakers right
yeah I don't think so I don't see anyone
playing with them they just make them
very colorful right and very expensive
they were always colorful but yeah they
were they were just badass
oh yeah
literally like Uzi guns they don't do
that [__] no more does uh taika do gun
fights with his
they run all over the house and shoot
each other oh I just say not the face
but they could shoot whatever else oh
they actually have projectiles like Nerf
yeah yeah like little darts that come
out Nerf Nerf is amazing I love Nerf I
had this bow and arrow where it shot one
giant missile you just had one shot so
you have to make a count
and this was uh I was like 25. oh no
those are good I named it Mike dong
after your buddy wow what a name
and it whistles right yeah it's accurate
as [__] dude
[Music]